il ya quelques jours j'étais invitée au
mariage de ma cousine et de sa femme
c'est marrant parce que quand je les dis
à mes potes ils m'ont tous sortis la
même phrase
le week-end prochain je lai un mariage
assez chiant ça homosexuels oh c'est
roussety lui alors je suis obligé de
leur répondre n'importe quoi c'est juste
un mariage normales en 2013
l'union de deux personnes qui s'aiment
légalement voilà j'avoue c'est trop
stylé en vrai avant le mariage me suis
posé une question
elles vont porter quoi exactement une
robe costume d'agent savais rien et
quand j'ai demandé à ma cousine a m'a
répondu tu verras au mariage et le jour
du mariage vous avez chacune une robe
une robe blanche et une noire or quand
je les ai vus je l'aurais fait à le
blanc le noir le yin et le yang
la complémentarité l'union pas mal non
c'est juste que j'aime bien le blanc et
moi le noir c'est un peu inyang quand
même non c'est une question de goût
hockey ces lignes en est en fait le truc
que j'attendais plus pendant ce mariage
c'était quand le maire devait dire je
vous déclare mari et femme
qu'est ce qu'il a qu'est ce qu'il allait
dire du coup je vous déclare femme et
femme du coup j'attendais que ça qui
sors ta phrase et au nom de la loi
oh oui je vous déclare à ses pilotes
10le unis par les liens du mariage
ah mais non on sentait que le maire ce
salut changer un petit peu de son
quotidien ce mariage d'ailleurs moment
et s'est même fait un kiff avec une
petite blague parce que je suis très
content de ce mariage puisque je vais
pouvoir faire la bise à deux mariés au
lieu d'une
jean louis meunier a toujours rêvé
d'être humoriste et fait rire la foule
des plus grandes salles parisiennes
sous la pression familiale il reste dans
sa commune où il finira mer parfois il
repense à sa vocation perdu ce qui le
plonge dans une profonde dépression
ah oui j'ai oublié un petit détail ma
grand mère a disparu juste avant le
mariage elle n'est pas morte elle était
juste perdu juste avant la cérémonie
disparu pourtant c'était dans un tout
petit village tout petit impossible de
perdre qui que ce soit or qu'est-ce
qu'est ce qu'on devait faire
est-ce qu'on annule le mariage pour
retrouver la grand-mère ou est ce qu'on
fait quand même le mariage sans la grand
mère c'est ce qu'on a fait finalement du
coup j'ai passé toute la cérémonie comme
ça ah c'est beau de voir ma cousine s'y
épanouit peut-être que j'ai pu de
grand-mère et on a retrouvé ma grand
mère juste après le mariage
elle était en fait dans le mariage d'en
face à l'église qui était au même moment
je ne sais pas comment il a pu se
tromper de mariage ça veut quand même
dire qu'elle a passé 30 minutes dans le
mauvais mariage tranquille à ma petite
fille a choisi un homme finalement et
elle a changé de physique et toute ma
famille disparue mais attends d
alzheimer
ensuite il une soirée dans la salle des
fêtes où il y avait un petit peu tout le
monde même le maire que c'était un tout
petit village et on a dû faire un truc
que je déteste écrire un mot dans le
livre d'or et j'ai quand même essayé de
la jouer très très très sobre et j'ai
quand même fait de la grosse merde vive
les mariés meilleurs des meilleurs
d'oublier le haut alors cousin talecris
quoi rien avait fait voir non non non
non non j'ai pas terminée j'ai pas
terminée je termine alors du coup j'ai
signé avec une écriture bizarre pour
faire croire que j'écris tout le temps
comme ça
j'ai une écriture un peu bizarre c'est
marrant à part ça c'était un super
mariage c'était touchant et en même
temps on s'est bien amusés tout le monde
était sympa même le maire a je dois y
aller je vous laisse bienne
j'avais juste un dernier mot pour vous
les internautes pour vous remercier tout
simplement puisque depuis quelques
semaines la chaîne youtube est arrivé en
tête du classement en france je suis
très honoré d'être le premier youtuber
français c'est grâce à vous c'est grâce
à vous et juste en faisant un petit clic
vous avez permis ça alors pour vous
remercier
je vais faire encore plein d'autres
vidéos ciao